And the persona is the mask that you
wear.
And that's what persona means is the
mask that you wear to convince yourself
and the world that you're not a terrible
monster.
So that when you look at yourself in the
mirror,
you don't have to run away screaming.
You know,
when you might think,
well that's a bit of an overstatement,
but you'll was very interested in
phenomena such as,
um,
say psychological,
the psychological phenomena that would
characterize the actions of someone who
might be an Auschwitz camp guard for
example.
And uh,
you know,
that's pretty monstrous form of
behavior.
And the thing about Auschwitz camp
guards is that there's no reason to
assume really that they were much
different than normal people.
Now,
there would have been exceptions
obviously,
but,
and what that means is that perhaps you
two could be an Auschwitz camp guard and
perhaps he would even derive some
enjoyment out of it.
And you might think not,
but you shouldn't think not so quickly.
And what that also implies is that if
you could see what that meant when you
looked in the mirror and looked at
yourself,
you might run away screaming because
you'd have a revelation of just exactly
what the human being is capable of.
And that's a very unpleasant revelation.
And also one of the things that stops
people from being enlightened because
that revelation of the evil of the self
is part of the journey to enlightenment
and an early part.